il est 18h10 heure locale lorsque deux
très forte explosion secoue le port de
beyrouth
une grande partie de la capitale et
ravagé par le souffle des détonations
réuni d'urgence le conseil supérieur de
la défense du pays a estimé que les
déflagrations serait dû à l'explosion
dans un entrepôt de 2007 150 tonnes de
nitrate d'ammonium selon des témoins la
déflagration aurait été entendus jusqu'à
chypre à 200 kilomètres des côtes
libanaises
l'ondé de choc a provoqué des
destructions partielles ou totales de
bâtiments des incendies et
d'innombrables dégâts dans toute la
ville sur des kilomètres dans la soirée
le premier ministre
hassan diab a affirmé que les
responsables de cette catastrophe
devront payer le prix de cette tragédie
ceux qui sont à l'origine de cette
catastrophe seront tenus pour
responsables c'est une promesse faite
aux martyrs et aux blessés
c'est un engagement national il y aura
des vérités qui seront révélées sur cet
entrepôt dangereux qui est là depuis
depuis plus de six ans non stop harper
cote
le liban a appelé à l'aide
internationale le gouvernement israélien
se serait adressé au gouvernement
libanais par le biais de médiateurs
internationaux pour offrir à beyrouth
une aide humanitaire et médicale
de son côté la france a fait savoir
qu'elle se tenait au côté du liban
la russie partage la douleur du peuple
libanais veuillez transmettre des mots
de compassion et de soutien aux familles
et aux proches des victimes ainsi que
nos voeux de prompt rétablissement à
tous les blessés j'exprime ma solidarité
fraternelle avec les libanais après
l'explosion qui a fait tant de victimes
et de dégâts ce soir à beyrouth
la france se tient aux côtés du liban
toujours des secours et moyens français
sont en cours d'acheminement
sur place les nombreux blessés ont
afflué rapidement vers les hôpitaux de
la capitale submergé des scènes de chaos
qui ont choqué les habitants de beyrouth
et marc stein abobo
et tout d'un coup nous avons senti un
boom tout a basculé
j'étais à la maison dans mon lit à
regarder la télévision la fenêtre m'est
tombé dessus
l'armoire nous est aussi tombé dessus ma
fille s'est blessé au bras et elle a
besoin d'une opération maintenant mon
autre fille s'est blessé à la main et au
doigt ma cousine est handicapée elle ne
peut pas marcher
nous étions à la maison nous avons
entendu le bruit des avions au dessus de
notre maison nous vivons à l'étagé
supérieur du bâtiment
nous avons entendu un fort bruit d'avion
et soudain le plafond nous tombe dessus
quelque chose exploser tout tombe avec
les murs le vert tout nous sommes sortis
ma mère dans une direction et moi dans
une autre je bougeais et j'ai ressenti
comme un tremblement de terre nous avons
pensé que c'est un tremblement de terre
nous avons regardé autour de nous et
nous avons vu du verre brisé partout ici
j'avais du verre brisé et là aussi tout
a été endommagée l'explosion a secoué la
terre ça ne ressemblait pas à une
explosion mais à une explosion l'une
après l'autre
parmi les victimes de l'explosion figure
nizar najarian secrétaire général du
parti kataeb l'une des formations
historiques de la droite chrétienne
l'onu au liban a affirmé de son côté que
des casques bleus avaient été grièvement
blessées à bord d'un navire des membres
du personnel de l'ambassade d'allemagne
et du royaume uni ont aussi été blessés
déjà miné par la corruption les
difficultés économiques les immenses
dégâts provoqués par les explosions
risque d'aggraver fortement la situation
du pays du cèdre
le premier ministre hassan diab a
décrété une journée de deuil national ce
mercredi